americans getting fed up with president
biden and his incompetent administration
a new poll showing americans very
frustrated with the president they think
biden is out of touch with the most
pressing issues the top three words used
to describe how the administration is
making people feel so far frustrated
disappointed and nervous
the problem isn't just with biden the
whole democrat party seems to be out of
touch with the american people who are
suffering and old guards like james
carville are issuing this warning watch
i think a lot of the democratic base has
not been told or informed of the things
that that president biden and and this
congress has accomplished democrats
whine too much chuck just quit being a
whiny party and get out there and and
fight and tell people what you did and
tell people the exact truth
nah that's no fun
so harold ford jr we've got a couple of
clinton nights uh trying to frame what's
happening with these horrible numbers
you say you have james carville
obviously saying quit being a whiny
party but then joe lockhart who once did
the job that dana perino did for george
w bush he was president clinton's
spokesperson he's saying that the
coverage is unfair the press coverage of
joe biden has just been unfair and he
thought you were going to get a dividend
for bringing normalcy back to america so
where do you stand harold ford jr
i'm more with the the carville i think
james carville
not only is he saying stop whining does
it does it apply to to biden i think it
also applies to
you know stop whining about press
coverage
dana knows as well as anyone you're
going to get negative coverage and
positive coverage uh but you can't bank
on you can only bank on a negative
coverage and hope you get some positive
coverage i think carville had it right
tout the accomplishments but i would add
a couple of more things one you got to
fix the border and you got to
demonstrate that you have a policy and
that you are paying attention to and
that you're going to work to get it done
two i'd create a supply chain task force
so every week we give a sense of what we
were doing to unclog those lanes that
are making it harder and really
impossible for goods to get into the
country which all in many ways is
contributing heavily to inflation uh to
inflation woes three stop trying to be
the senate leader mr president be
president use the bully pulpit advance
your agenda that way leave the process
to senator schumer and speaker pelosi
you ought to get out and explain what's
in what you want why you want it and ask
the country to support it and finally
give joe manchin what he wants on
buildback better put it on the floor and
take the dog on victory in front of you
hfj 2024 love to see you
um all right so
jesse that's great advice tell your
accomplishments but when you have the
supreme court striking down your vaccine
mandate you have inflation that's
ravaging the country and hurting
low-income earners and then you have a
senator from your very own party
turning down
modifying the filibuster
what are the accomplishments exactly
jesse there are no accomplishments to
tell james is concerned with marketing
this is not about marketing this is
about a product no one wants the product
biden is selling he's like the sales guy
that keeps on trying to sell you
something that you're not there to buy
there used to be a guy in long island i
used to go to the store
and i used to go in for say christmas
lights he'd be like mike
where are the christmas lights what
aisle
and he'd be like no no no no let me
first show you these adirondack chairs
mr waters is it mike i'm here for the
lights i don't want adirondack chairs
you say no no no sit down in these
chairs trust me you're going to love
these chairs i sit down to humor them i
say mike they're great chairs
but i need christmas lights
and he says you know what i'm going to
do don't tell the manager jesse i'm
going to knock off 10 of these chairs
don't tell anybody
i'm going to do this for you they're
basically free when you think about it
and
i said what are you talking about mike
um first of all these chairs have
stickers on them that say sold because
oh well not these chairs these are floor
samples but they're back ordered and
you're going to get these chairs in
about six months
so it's the same thing with biden like
he's selling us something that we don't
want and the stuff he is selling us he
can't even deliver like the voting thing
and build back better so what are we
doing all we want is a nimble
administration that's able to pivot away
from their pre-planned political agenda
and towards the agenda of the american
people the things that we care about now
today and they can't do it no because
the american people are busy getting
blamed for all of this dana and i think
that's part of what is driving these
poll numbers down you know you had a
quinnipiac poll last week uh that you
talked about 33 percent you know the the
average polling the average approval
rating for the president is anywhere
from 40 to 44
still not good so you know what can they
possibly do to make things better when
their policies to jesse's point what the
american public what they've actually
bought are making things worse and
exacerbating things like in inflation so
what do you do to make it better well
the quinnipiac poll definitely lit a
fire under some democrats because it was
a shocking one and it was considered
possibly an outlier right so they wrote
a memo from the white house and
basically saying this is not really the
case biden's actually fairly popular
everything's fine and the ink was not
even dry on that memo when the new cbs
poll came out which basically kind of
reiterated what it was said what the
quinnipiac said and
one of the big focuses
is the word focus in this poll one of
the things i thought it was interesting
is only 33 think biden and democrats are
focused on the key issues they care a
lot about so they are selling adirondack
chairs when we came in for christmas
lights and people are irritated about it
now polls like this with a trajectory
you would expect to see some sort of
possible leadership change or major
change in direction but everything i'm
picking up is that there's not there's
not one that they're going to continue
to try to drive on voting rights in
particular and it's likely that they
will lose that vote again tomorrow
interesting so you know dana's talking
about some of the numbers greg 40 of the
country in the cbs poll 40
uh say they're nervous about this
administration we're still in the first
year
of this president's first term what is
year two going to be like oh
just thinking about how adirondack
chairs are so uncomfortable for short
people you guys don't understand it but
like if dangerous
you have to sit your ass all the way
back to the chair and then you're it's
just not kind you can't find a way to
sit in them
and and then you get a splinter and i
now i'm just that's all i've been
thinking about for this entire segment
all right here's the weird thing about
these numbers this is what's crazy okay
joe lockhart saying the media by the way
in scientific terms he is a gibbering
[ __ ] i think we've understood this for
a while but you have to understand
there's actually very very very little
bad coverage
about joe biden if you step i mean we
talk about it all the time but that's
because that's what we do on this but
there's very little bad coverage on him
but it's not necessary because his
ineptitude and decrepitude has become
part of mainstream culture it's like you
don't have to talk that bad about him
you don't have to criticize because it's
kind of been understood that this is
kind of what we're stuck with and it's
probably
and the saddest part about it is and
i've beaten a dead horse here quite
literally joe put woke wokism before the
welfare of the country you have some
really really really big issues here
whether it's crime fentanyl poisoning uh
inflation covid the border these are
things that affect every citizen black
or white you name it right but instead
joe is like you know january 6th voting
rights pronouns he's basically aoc in a
bad grandpa rubber suit and and you and
we had we did get sold like some bad
adirondack chairs i think the best
advice for the dems besides running uh
harold 2024 is to develop a few more
tools than race politics and woke
apologism right there the issues are
sitting there man the republicans are
generally slow if you can beat them to
it but you got to let go of this stuff
the symbolic cya social justice the
energy they put into that could power a
small city a nauseating small city like
portland
yeah and they can all go live there have
a great time yes hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else